This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with mental health issues and co-occurring disorders. Newport's programs take into account the extraordinary pressures facing young people today and the collective trauma and stress prompted by national and international events. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. In the two months since Russia invaded Ukraine, more than 4 million Ukrainians have had to flee the country as refugees. More than 6 million others have been internally displaced, and tens of millions more are living through shelling, food shortages, and other traumas of war. In March, the Director General of the World Health Organization said that services for mental health and psychological support were urgently needed to help Ukrainians co-eastern. with the effects of war. What does that need look like on the ground?
本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，他们为12至28岁正受心理健康问题和共病困扰的青少年及年轻人提供以结果为导向的治疗。Newport的课程充分考虑了当今年轻人所面临的巨大压力，以及国家和国际事件所引发的集体创伤与压力。欲了解更多信息，请访问newporthealthcare.com。自俄罗斯入侵乌克兰以来的两个月里，已有超过400万乌克兰人被迫作为难民逃离该国。另有超过600万人流离失所，数千万人正经历着炮火、食物短缺和其他战争创伤。今年3月，世界卫生组织总干事表示，迫切需要提供心理健康和心理支持服务，以帮助乌克兰人应对战争带来的影响。在实地，这种需求是什么样的？
What are the most pressing mental health issues during wartime? And what kind of support can psychologists and other mental health providers offer? What do we know about the short and long-term effects of living through war for both children and adults? And how have telemedicine and remote services change the kinds of mental health support available in this war compared with past conflicts? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Laura Murray, a senior scientist at the Johns Hopkins University School
战时最紧迫的心理健康问题是什么？心理学家和其他心理健康服务提供者能提供什么样的支持？对于经历战争的儿童和成人，我们对战争的短期和长期影响了解多少？与过去的冲突相比，远程医疗和远程服务如何改变了这场战争中可获得的心理健康支持类型？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是约翰·霍普金斯大学公共卫生学院的高级科学家劳拉·默里博士。
of Public Health, where she is co-founder of the Applied Mental Health Research Group. Dr. Murray is a clinical psychologist by training and works to develop mental and behavioral health programs in low-resource countries. She and her colleagues have been working in eastern Ukraine since 2015, helping people affected by the ongoing conflict there. Dr. Murray's work has also taken her to Zambia, Lebanon, Cambodia, Honduras, and many other parts of the globe. Her focus is on studying the effectiveness, acceptability, and scalability of a wide range of evidence-based treatments for mental and behavioral health problems, with a particular special special. in researching and treating trauma and grief.
她是应用心理健康研究小组的联合创始人。默里博士是一位受过专业训练的临床心理学家，致力于在资源匮乏的国家开发心理和行为健康项目。她和同事自2015年以来一直在乌克兰东部工作，帮助受当地持续冲突影响的人们。默里博士的工作足迹还遍布赞比亚、黎巴嫩、柬埔寨、洪都拉斯和全球许多其他地区。她的研究重点是研究各种循证心理和行为健康治疗方法的有效性、可接受性和可扩展性，尤其擅长创伤和悲伤的研究与治疗。
Dr. Murray, thank you for joining me today. Wonderful to be here. Thanks so much, Kim. Let's start with the first question I asked in the introduction. I mentioned that the World Health Organization said recently that there's an urgent need for mental health support for Ukrainians. What does that look like? What are people's most pressing mental health needs right now and what kind of support can mental health providers give during wartime? time. I agree that mental health needs are extreme and going to be extreme for the years to come,
默里博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。很高兴来到这里。非常感谢，金。让我们从我在介绍中提出的第一个问题开始。我提到世界卫生组织最近表示，乌克兰人迫切需要心理健康支持。那是什么样的？人们目前最紧迫的心理健康需求是什么？在战时，心理健康服务提供者能提供什么样的支持？我同意心理健康需求是极端的，而且在未来几年内都将是极端的。
given the situation in Ukraine. When you ask, what are the most pressing mental health needs, it will change over time. It's very dependent on a large number of variables right now. Ukraine is a little bit different in the context that some people are still in country. And in country, in places that are different levels of safety. Some are in country and safe. Some are in country and not in safe places. And then, of course, as you mentioned, there are millions of refugees who have fled the country and are in different locations.
鉴于乌克兰的局势。当你问什么是目前最紧迫的心理健康需求时，它会随着时间而改变。目前这在很大程度上取决于大量的变量。乌克兰的情况有些不同，因为有些人仍然留在国内。在国内，人们处于不同安全程度的地方。有些人留在国内且处于安全地带。有些人留在国内，但处于不安全的地方。当然，正如你提到的，还有数百万难民逃离了该国，身处不同的地点。
So what we see is a vast array of variables that are affecting this humanitarian crisis. The mental health needs are going to be vast. They're going to be very different. and they're going to be ever-changing. It's not a stretch to say that in any humanitarian context or war, what we see is an increase in anxiety and stress and post-traumatic stress disorder and depression and some substance use. One of the biggest things that we focus on is the difference in time.
所以我们看到的是影响这场人道主义危机的大量变量。心理健康需求将是巨大的。它们将非常不同，而且会不断变化。毫不夸张地说，在任何人道主义环境或战争中，我们看到的都是焦虑、压力、创伤后应激障碍、抑郁和某些药物滥用的增加。我们关注的最大问题之一是时间上的差异。
So, for example, Kim, you mentioned what is the need now? Right now, when people are living through this, situation, that elevated anxiety is very normal. And it's really important not to pathologize that and say that that's abnormal, right? So many people might look like they're agitated. And that's good that will serve them well, especially if they're still in an unsafe context. So mental health needs really vary right now. What we're seeing is that there's a lot of need for psychological first aid. That's an evidence-based, an approach that really is given in the context of ongoing disasters, wars, humanitarian settings, focuses more on support and prevention, and that's really
例如，金，你提到了现在的需求是什么？此时此刻，当人们正在经历这种状况时，这种升高的焦虑是非常正常的。重要的是不要将其病理化，不要说这是异常的，对吧？许多人看起来可能很焦躁。这很好，这会对他们有帮助，特别是如果他们仍然处于不安全的环境中。所以心理健康需求目前确实各不相同。我们看到的是，对心理急救的需求很大。这是一种循证方法，确实是在持续的灾难、战争、人道主义环境中提供的，更多地关注支持和预防，这非常关键。
critical. I would say in the past week, we've started to see some movement towards needing more than psychological first aid, particularly for those people that are now somewhere safer. so they're out of the immediate danger and they're starting to experience some exaggerated symptoms or some additional struggles. So how does providing mental health care during a war differ from other kinds of mental health care? Yeah, so during a war, what we want to really be careful of is what I alluded to earlier that in the context of a war, many reactions that might look like a mental health problem are actually very normal. So if anyone was in that context, they would, they, it would be very normal to have, you know, reduced sleep and we couldn't function as much, and it would be hard to problem solve, and we would be anxious.
我想说，在过去的一周里，我们开始看到一些转向需要不仅仅是心理急救的趋势，特别是对于那些现在身处更安全地方的人来说。他们脱离了直接危险，开始经历一些夸大的症状或一些额外的挣扎。那么，在战争期间提供心理健康护理与其他类型的心理健康护理有何不同？是的，所以在战争期间，我们真正需要小心的是我之前提到的，在战争背景下，许多看起来像是心理健康问题的反应实际上是非常正常的。所以如果任何人处于那种环境中，睡眠减少、功能受损、难以解决问题、感到焦虑，这都是非常正常的。
And so that's one of the biggest differences. And in regular mental health care, we're looking for symptoms like that to indicate this might be a area where we want to intervene to help reduce that in a disaster war setting, what we want to be careful of is taking into account the context and what's a normal response to a really awful situation. And then how is the best way that we can help them? The other difference I will say is that, you know, in a situation like Ukraine and many other wars and disasters, for example, we really want to get basic needs first because that really causes a lot of the stress. So in a war context, that's going to look differently and that even though someone looks anxious, our response wouldn't be to provide mental health care.
这就是最大的区别之一。在常规的心理健康护理中，我们寻找这样的症状来表明这可能是一个我们需要干预以帮助减少这些症状的领域。在灾难战争环境中，我们需要小心的是考虑到背景，以及对极其糟糕的情况的正常反应。然后我们能帮助他们的最好方式是什么？我要说的另一个区别是，在乌克兰和许多其他战争和灾难的情况下，例如，我们确实想首先满足基本需求，因为这确实导致了很大的压力。所以在战争背景下，情况会有所不同，即使有人看起来很焦虑，我们的反应也不会是提供心理健康护理。
Our response would be to say, what is going on? Do you have food? Do you have water? Right. You need housing. Housing. How is your children? Like, how are your children? Do you have an injury? And so it's mental health usually comes later or is more preventive in nature, in nature. for example, like the psychological first aid. So what are providers in Ukraine experiencing right now? One big question that I had is, are there still mental health providers on the ground in Ukraine or have they left as well? And for those who are there, they must be going through their own trauma.
我们的反应会是问：发生了什么？你有食物吗？你有水吗？对。你需要住房。住房。你的孩子怎么样？你的孩子还好吗？你受伤了吗？所以心理健康通常来得较晚，或者本质上更具预防性，例如心理急救。那么乌克兰的服务提供者现在正在经历什么？我有一个很大的疑问，乌克兰当地还有心理健康服务提供者吗？还是他们也离开了？对于那些留在那里的人，他们一定也在经历自己的创伤。
So how are they helping other people when they need help themselves? I'm so happy you brought this up, Kim. In our time there, we have trained over 200 mental health professionals. And I will tell you, it's so challenging for them. And yet we see such resilience and such desire to care for their fellow Ukrainians. I will say as far as location, they're all over. There's many that are still in Ukraine. There's many that are sort of around the outskirts of Ukraine.
那么当他们自己也需要帮助时，他们是如何帮助别人的呢？我很高兴你提到了这一点，金。在我们待在那里的时间里，我们培训了200多名心理健康专业人员。我可以告诉你，这对他们来说太具有挑战性了。然而，我们看到了他们如此强大的韧性，以及照顾同胞的强烈愿望。关于地点，我想说他们分布在各地。有许多人仍然留在乌克兰。有许多人处于乌克兰周边地区。
in safer areas. There's many that still are moving quite a bit. And then there's many that probably have left and have gone, you know, outside of the country. What are they doing? You know, I think it varies a lot. There are some that are having to take care of their elderly parents. We know some that have not only their young children with them, but many other families, young children's. So there's a lot of people taking other people's minors because maybe something happened to the parents or, as we all know, many men are still in country fighting and or they're not allowed to leave. And so there's a lot of additional family members that some of these providers are taking on. We are saying in our team, they're still responding to needs. You see
在更安全的地方。有许多人仍在不断转移。还有许多人可能已经离开并去了国外。他们在做什么？你知道，我认为差异很大。有些人不得不照顾年迈的父母。我们知道有些人不仅带着年幼的孩子，还带着许多其他家庭的年幼孩子。所以有很多人在照顾别人的未成年人，因为可能父母发生了什么事，或者正如我们所知，许多男人仍然留在国内战斗，或者他们不被允许离开。所以这些服务提供者中的一些人承担了许多额外的家庭成员。我们看到我们的团队仍然在响应需求。你看到
them very active on social media on Facebook, posting good prevention things, telling people how to take care of themselves. They have a great network online of support that they're providing. And I would say one of the biggest roles that our team has played is making sure that we check in with these providers to say, I know you want to work all the time, but you're still in a place of you just left. You've lost everything. You haven't had time to process. What just happened to you? So even though oftentimes for all of us, it's our natural instinct to dive back into work or help each other in this situation, we're also very mindful of, you know, how can we make sure we help these providers take care of themselves and take the time that they need,
他们在社交媒体和Facebook上非常活跃，发布好的预防措施，告诉人们如何照顾自己。他们在线上有一个很棒的支持网络。我想说，我们的团队所扮演的最大角色之一是确保我们与这些服务提供者沟通，告诉他们：我知道你们想一直工作，但你们仍然处于刚离开的状态。你们失去了一切。你们还没有时间处理刚刚发生的事情。所以，尽管对我们所有人来说，本能地投入工作或在这种情况下互相帮助是天性，但我们也时刻提醒自己，我们如何确保帮助这些服务提供者照顾好自己，并抽出他们需要的时间。
as you said, Kim, they just went through horrific things, even if they're somewhere safe now, journey out, as we know, has been awful for so many. So are there stages to care in a situation like this? I think you alluded to that, that you start with mental health first aid, and you also deal with getting people the basics that they need to survive, but then what? Right. So, of course, in wars and humanitarian, everything is basic needs, medical supplies, things like that. We want to address all of that first. And the real, any time mental health would come into play there would be psychological first aid, which is really just about asking what they need for basic support, trying to elevate who do they
正如你所说，金，他们刚刚经历了可怕的事情，即使他们现在身处安全的地方，正如我们所知，对于许多人来说，逃离的旅程也是极其糟糕的。那么在这种情况下，护理有阶段吗？我想你已经提到了，你从心理急救开始，也要处理人们生存所需的基本需求，但接下来呢？是的，当然，在战争和人道主义救援中，一切都是基本需求，医疗用品等等。我们想首先解决所有这些问题。心理健康在其中发挥作用的任何时候，都将是心理急救，这实际上只是询问他们需要什么基本支持，试图提升他们身边有什么人可以支持他们，你可以给谁打电话，你如何与他们建立联系，你需要什么来与他们建立联系？所以这是一个很棒的预防工具和非常有支持性的干预措施。
have to support them, who can you call, how are you connected with them, what do you need to get connected with them? So it's a wonderful prevention tool and a very supportive intervention. from there, one of the things we've done in our global work is think about different stages of treatment. And so there's a lot of great prevention work that's still very evidence-based. For example, these one-session things that are still evidence-based, there are sessions, but you're teaching people a skill that they can use in the future. That might be a next stage. So, for example, in psychology, we have an evidence-based CBT tool called Cognitive coping,
从那里开始，我们在全球工作中做的一件事是思考治疗的不同阶段。所以有很多很棒的预防工作仍然是非常基于证据的。例如，这些仍然基于证据的单次会话，虽然是会话，但你是在教人们未来可以使用的技能。这可能是下一个阶段。例如，在心理学中，我们有一种基于证据的CBT工具，称为认知应对，
which is just a fancy way of sort of saying we learn to think about things differently or use different self-talk, which can really affect our emotions. So for example, instead of constantly saying, my life is over, everything's changed, I'm never going to get back, I'm never going to learn. learn about my family, those thoughts, if you say them to yourself all day long, they're not going to help you. So in a situation where you can't change the context right now, one of the most powerful tools we have as individuals is to change the way that we think about it. Now, that doesn't mean your thoughts become ridiculously positive, right? We're not saying you're thinking,
这只是一种花哨的说法，即我们学会以不同的方式思考事物或使用不同的自我对话，这确实会影响我们的情绪。例如，与其整天说：我的生活结束了，一切都变了，我永远回不去了，我永远无法了解我的家人，这些想法，如果你整天对自己说，它们不会对你有帮助。所以在你目前无法改变环境的情况下，我们作为个人拥有的最强大的工具之一就是改变我们思考它的方式。现在，这并不意味着你的想法变得荒谬地积极，对吧？我们不是说你在想，
oh, everything's great. But a minor change to that thought. So, for example, I have lost so much, but at least my children are safe with me. Even that little change gives our brains just an amazing ability to have an impact on our feelings, change the chemicals that are going around. There's so much great evidence that that really can move you towards a more helpful, positive demeanor. If nothing else, even just to help your brain get a little bit more healthy so that you can start problem solving, which we know a lot of people are having to do constantly.
哦，一切都很棒。但对那个想法做一个微小的改变。例如，我失去了很多，但至少我的孩子们和我在一起是安全的。即使是那一点点改变，也能给我们的大脑带来惊人的能力，对我们的感受产生影响，改变体内循环的化学物质。有大量很好的证据表明，这确实可以让你转向一种更有帮助、更积极的举止。如果什么都做不了，至少可以帮助你的大脑变得稍微健康一点，这样你就可以开始解决问题，我们知道很多人必须不断地这样做。
So some of those types of short, skill-based, but yet very scientifically strong interventions can be really helpful as very short, helpful, helpful programs. From there, I think there's a couple of things I would say. One is you really need to start looking at very short assessments that can help triage. that's one of the biggest things in disaster and humanitarian. You also don't want to send everyone to mental health care. Not everyone will need it. It's hard to imagine, but people are amazingly resilient.
所以其中一些短期的、基于技能但科学性很强的干预措施可以作为非常简短、有益的项目发挥作用。从那里开始，我想说有几件事。一是你真的需要开始着眼于可以帮助分诊的非常简短的评估。这是灾难和人道主义救援中最大的事情之一。你也不想把每个人都送到心理健康护理机构。并不是每个人都需要它。很难想象，但人们的韧性令人惊叹。
So there's a lot of people who will go through horrific experiences and actually be okay. And so it's really important to think about mental health care, not only in the context of serving people, but serving them incorrectly triaging to the appropriate service. And so someone might just need a little tweak, a little help, maybe they just need more psychological first aid. And then these short assessments can also really say, wow, you're really struggling a little bit more. We'd like to send you to what we would consider more of a full treatment. So you mentioned children a moment ago, and many of the refugees and other victims of the war in Ukraine are kids. I saw an estimate that the war has displaced more than half of Ukraine's children.
所以有很多人会经历可怕的经历，但实际上会没事的。因此，不仅要在服务人们的背景下思考心理健康护理，还要在正确分诊到适当服务的背景下思考，这一点非常重要。所以有人可能只需要一点点调整，一点点帮助，也许他们只需要更多的心理急救。然后这些简短的评估也可以真正说明，哇，你确实在挣扎得稍微多一点。我们想把你送到我们认为更全面的治疗中去。所以你刚才提到了孩子，乌克兰战争的许多难民和其他受害者都是孩子。我看到一个估计，战争已经使乌克兰一半以上的儿童流离失所。
What do we know about the long-term mental health effects of experiencing war as a child? Yes, it's awful to see what's happening with children. We know that with children, just like adults, the impact of war can be devastating. Some reactions, again, include behavioral problems, depression, anxiety, post-traumatic stress disorder. Often in kids, problems are presented that look more behavioral, even like something attention, deficit, hyperactivity like. Sometimes it's functional impairment, big disruptions in eating and sleep can happen.
我们对儿童经历战争的长期心理健康影响了解多少？是的，看到孩子们身上发生的事情太可怕了。我们知道，对于儿童，就像成人一样，战争的影响可能是毁灭性的。一些反应再次包括行为问题、抑郁、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍。在孩子身上，问题通常表现得更像行为问题，甚至像注意力缺陷多动障碍。有时是功能障碍，饮食和睡眠的巨大中断可能会发生。
In wars, there tends to be a much greater number of children affected by mental health rather than the general population. I should also add, though, again, children are amazingly resilient. And I think one of the challenges we often have is that people see a war and they assume everyone's going to have PTSD. And science tells us that that is incorrect. We know that kids also can be resilient. One of the best things to do for kids, again, is make sure those parents are healthier or is healthy. or as healthy as they can be, because that's a huge preventative factor for kids,
在战争中，受心理健康影响的儿童数量往往比一般人群多得多。不过，我也应该补充一点，孩子们是非常有韧性的。我认为我们经常面临的挑战之一是，人们看到战争，就假设每个人都会患上创伤后应激障碍。科学告诉我们这是不正确的。我们知道孩子们也可以有韧性。对孩子来说，最好的事情之一再次是确保那些父母更健康，或者尽可能健康，因为这对孩子来说是一个巨大的预防因素，
them feeling safe and connected. And then just some of that prevention work for kids, because, again, kids are so resilient. And then really identifying what children are really having, you know, ongoing problems based on the war. Now, you and your colleagues have been working in Ukraine since about 2015, right? Correct. What took you to Ukraine at that point? And then the program, what's it like that you've been running in Ukraine all of these years? Yeah.
让他们感到安全和联系。然后就是针对孩子的一些预防工作，因为孩子们确实非常有韧性。然后真正识别出哪些孩子确实因为战争而出现了持续的问题。现在，你和你的同事自2015年左右就在乌克兰工作，对吧？没错。是什么让你在那时去了乌克兰？然后，这些年来你在乌克兰运行的项目是什么样的？是的。
So U.S.Aid Victims of Torture Fund has been providing resources for us to work in Ukraine for about eight years, really responding to the ongoing war in the East. And so we had a couple stages in this. we always go into a new setting where we haven't worked, and we try to do some qualitative work to understand what does the local population say are the biggest problems and maybe the holes in services. As many of you likely know, Ukraine is a very educated country. They have a lot of psychologists and mental health professionals.
所以美国国际开发署（USAID）酷刑受害者基金一直在为我们在乌克兰的工作提供资源，大约八年了，主要是为了应对东部持续的战争。所以我们在这个过程中有几个阶段。我们总是进入一个我们从未工作过的新环境，我们尝试做一些定性工作，以了解当地人口认为最大的问题是什么，以及服务中可能存在的缺口。正如你们许多人可能知道的那样，乌克兰是一个受教育程度很高的国家。他们有很多心理学家和心理健康专业人员。
So that qualitative look is really important to understand what services already exist. let's not bring services that aren't needed. We're the areas that need help. Then USAID supported us to make sure we had some valid tools to assess and triage. That was one of the missing pieces and a very practical tool. So for those of you that are psychologists out there, sometimes, you know, we can spend hours and hours doing assessments that are really nice and rigorous in the field. We really want to make sure that we have something that's practical, usable, and quick,
所以这种定性观察对于了解已经存在哪些服务非常重要。让我们不要带来不需要的服务。哪些领域需要帮助。然后USAID支持我们确保我们有一些有效的工具来进行评估和分诊。这是缺失的部分之一，也是一个非常实用的工具。所以对于你们这些心理学家来说，有时，你知道，我们可以花几个小时做评估，这些评估在实地确实很好且严谨。我们确实想确保我们拥有实用、可用且快速的东西，
but also very valid and just as strong. And so USAID supported us to do that. Our third big project there was to actually run a trial to understand if CETA, which is the common elements treatment approach, is more or less effective, whether it's given at its normal length versus a short, version. So we were testing, could you give a five-session version of CETA and what was the differential effectiveness to the average, which is around eight? So we did that evaluation. And then the last few years, what we've been really doing is working on scaling, sustainability. So we've
但也非常有效且同样强大。所以USAID支持我们这样做。我们在那里的第三个大项目是实际进行一项试验，以了解CETA（通用要素治疗方法）在正常长度与简短版本下是否更有效。所以我们正在测试，你是否可以提供五次会话版本的CETA，以及与平均水平（大约八次）相比的差异有效性。所以我们做了那个评估。然后在过去几年里，我们真正做的是致力于扩展和可持续性。所以我们
built supervisors and trainers of the CETA program, the CETA system of care. So they understand assessment, they understand triage, they understand implementation, they understand all the different levels of the CETA system of care. And then finally, what we did the last year or so is we've been finishing a separate study on these single sessions that I mentioned before. So what does it look like, for example, if we pull people in via a single session, especially those that are more hesitant to engage in mental health care, pull them in for a single session, get them oriented, diffuse some negative aspects that might be out there of negative opinions of psychological treatment, and then triage and refer for those that need additional help.
建立了CETA项目的督导和培训师，即CETA护理系统。所以他们了解评估，了解分诊，了解实施，了解CETA护理系统的所有不同层面。最后，我们在过去一年左右所做的是完成了一项关于我之前提到的这些单次会话的独立研究。所以，例如，如果我们通过单次会话吸引人们，特别是那些对参与心理健康护理比较犹豫的人，把他们吸引进来进行单次会话，让他们适应，消除可能存在的一些负面看法，即对心理治疗的负面意见，然后为那些需要额外帮助的人进行分诊和转介，这会是什么样子？
And now we're going to take a short break. This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing accessible and ethical treatment to young people ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with mental health concerns and behavioral issues, including depression, anxiety, and substance abuse. Newport's whole person trauma-informed approach acknowledges the psychological impact of national and international tragedies, whether close to home or far away. Newport offers a full continuum of care for teens and young adults with tailored treatment plans designed for each client's individual needs and history. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com.
现在我们要休息一下。本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，致力于为12至28岁正受心理健康问题和行为问题（包括抑郁、焦虑和药物滥用）困扰的年轻人提供可及且合乎道德的治疗。Newport以人为本的创伤知情方法承认国家和国际悲剧带来的心理影响，无论是在家门口还是远方。Newport为青少年和年轻人提供全方位的护理，并根据每位客户的个人需求和历史量身定制治疗计划。欲了解更多信息，请访问newporthealthcare.com。
So you're the co-developer of CETA, the Common Elements Treatment Approach, which, as I understand it, it's a blueprint for using evidence-based techniques to provide mental health care internationally. Can you talk a little bit about how it was developed and the basic elements, and I know it's being deployed in many places, not only in Ukraine? Yes, absolutely. So we talk about CETA is really a system of care where we really want to start with understanding at really solid implementation science, which then goes to assessment and triage and all the different levels of treatment.
你是CETA（通用要素治疗方法）的共同开发者，据我了解，它是国际上使用循证技术提供心理健康护理的蓝图。你能谈谈它是如何开发的以及基本要素吗？我知道它不仅在乌克兰，而且在许多地方都在部署。是的，绝对可以。所以我们谈论CETA实际上是一个护理系统，我们确实想从理解非常扎实的实施科学开始，然后进入评估和分诊以及治疗的所有不同层面。
The reason we started focused on developing the CETA system of care was that in our global work, as well as domestic work, we realized some problems. one of those problems is that we tend to address problems in silos. So someone will be treated for depression. And usually a psychologist specializes in one area or another. So if you know an evidence-based protocol for trauma, you don't know how to treat anxiety necessarily, you don't know how to treat substance use, et cetera.
我们开始专注于开发CETA护理系统的原因是，在全球工作以及国内工作中，我们意识到了一些问题。其中一个问题是我们倾向于孤立地解决问题。所以有人会因为抑郁症接受治疗。通常心理学家专攻一个领域或另一个领域。所以如果你知道一种针对创伤的循证方案，你不一定知道如何治疗焦虑，你不知道如何治疗药物滥用，等等。
So that was one of the challenges we found. A second challenge we found was that assessor were very long and just couldn't be done in a lot of these low resource settings, although in high resource settings, they cost us a lot of money anyway. So we sort of noticed that as a problem that we wanted to fix. So we wanted to address multiple problems. We wanted to come up with an assessment that addressed multiple problems, but in a way that was just as strong. And then we also wanted to create a treatment that could be age agnostic. So the other silo we really figured out was you're either trained to treat children, sometimes you even specialize in just adolescents or adults,
所以这是我们发现的挑战之一。我们发现的第二个挑战是评估非常长，在许多资源匮乏的环境中根本无法完成，尽管在高资源环境中，它们无论如何都要花费我们很多钱。所以我们注意到这是一个我们想要解决的问题。所以我们想解决多个问题。我们想提出一个解决多个问题的评估，但方式同样强大。然后我们还想创造一种可以不分年龄的治疗方法。所以我们真正发现的另一个孤立领域是，你要么受过治疗儿童的培训，有时你甚至只专攻青少年或成人，
and we found that that was a challenge. The fourth one that I'll just mention is we found that treatment care is rarely a system. It's either you're a full-fledged treatment or you're a separate prevention program and nothing really flowed together. So recipients of mental health care have to sort of bounce around different organizations and understand and there's no real connection of triage through the different levels of severity of need. And as we all know as humans, we sort of fluctuate between those needs throughout our life, right? Sometimes you're doing good. Sometimes we need a little help. Sometimes we need a lot of help. And then we fluctuate back. So we developed CEDA really to address those areas where we said this is what we see as scalable
我们发现这是一个挑战。我提到的第四点是，我们发现治疗护理很少是一个系统。你要么是全面的治疗，要么是单独的预防项目，没有什么真正融合在一起。所以心理健康护理的接受者必须在不同的组织之间来回奔波，而且没有真正的分诊连接来应对不同严重程度的需求。正如我们作为人类所知，我们在生活中会在这些需求之间波动，对吧？有时你做得很好。有时我们需要一点帮助。有时我们需要很多帮助。然后我们又波动回来。所以我们开发CETA确实是为了解决这些领域，我们说这是我们所看到的具有可扩展性
and sustainable mental health system of care. And over the past 20 years, we've been very systematically studying different parts of this all over the world in both low, middle, and high-income settings. And part of this involves training lay people. Is that right? And why would you be training lay people? Why is that an important facet of what it is that you're doing? Yeah.
和可持续性的心理健康护理系统。在过去的20年里，我们一直在世界各地低、中、高收入环境中非常系统地研究这部分的各个方面。这其中一部分涉及培训非专业人员。是这样吗？为什么要培训非专业人员？为什么这是你所做工作的一个重要方面？是的。
Well, in many of the contexts we work in low-no-income countries, there are no mental health-trained providers. So that's a little different in Ukraine, but in most of the world, that is the case. And global mental health as a field has actually taken on what the World Health Organization calls task shifting, which is treating using psychological programs and treatments, and training lay providers to deliver those. So that happens with a lot of treatments. It's not just CETA. That's been a movement in the global mental health arena.
嗯，在我们工作的许多低收入国家，没有受过心理健康培训的服务提供者。所以在乌克兰情况有点不同，但在世界大部分地区，情况确实如此。全球心理健康作为一个领域实际上已经采用了世界卫生组织所称的任务转移，即使用心理项目和治疗，并培训非专业服务提供者来提供这些服务。所以这在很多治疗中都会发生。不仅仅是CETA。这是全球心理健康领域的一场运动。
And the reason that's important, Kim, is there was no workforce in a lot of these places. So there was often no choice. I will say, though, that a second reason and one that I think is equally as powerful is there's an engagement challenge with mental health. health care. There's so much stigma. There's a real distance often between those that are providers and maybe the community they're trying to help. And there's often trust issues. And so what we found is by training lay providers who were part of the community we wanted to treat, you just got rid of all that. There was no stigma. There was automatic trust. And I will tell you,
金，这之所以重要，是因为在许多这些地方没有劳动力。所以往往没有选择。不过，我要说的是，第二个原因，我认为同样强大，是心理健康护理存在参与挑战。有太多的污名。服务提供者与他们试图帮助的社区之间往往存在真正的距离。而且往往存在信任问题。所以我们发现，通过培训作为我们想要治疗的社区一部分的非专业服务提供者，你只是消除了所有这些。没有污名。有自动的信任。而且我可以告诉你，
in Ukraine specifically, one of the populations we worked with a lot was veterans. And those veterans were much better found, addressed, treated by fellow veterans. And I think we know that across most of the world, including the United States. And so what our research, as well as so many others in the global mental health space has shown, is that lay providers can be taught evidence-based treatments, perform them very well with fidelity and get very good results. I think that's a little bit controversial in countries where there are providers because we don't want to take those jobs away. And so in Ukraine, we did train some lay providers in some aspects, but we also made sure that we were utilizing their existing mental health providers that were trained and had degrees.
在乌克兰，我们合作最多的群体之一是退伍军人。而那些退伍军人由退伍军人同伴来寻找、解决、治疗效果要好得多。我认为我们在世界大部分地区，包括美国，都知道这一点。所以我们的研究，以及全球心理健康领域的许多其他研究表明，非专业服务提供者可以被教授循证治疗，以保真度很好地执行它们，并获得非常好的结果。我认为这在有服务提供者的国家有点争议，因为我们不想夺走那些工作。所以在乌克兰，我们确实在某些方面培训了一些非专业服务提供者，但我们也确保利用了他们现有的受过培训并拥有学位的心理健康服务提供者。
Yeah. So Ukraine has endured great upheaval. through history and certainly going back to the early 20th century, right when the Bolsheviks invaded. And then, I mean, that's continued pretty much until this day, even after the demise of the Soviet Union. Now, since you've worked in Ukraine for the last eight or so years, what can you say about the collective mindset of a nation that has been a long-time target of one of its closest neighbors? Wow. That's an amazing question. And I, gosh, and I love history. They've had the Russians, you know, breathing down their necks for centuries.
是的。所以乌克兰在历史上经历了巨大的动荡，当然可以追溯到20世纪初，就在布尔什维克入侵时。然后，我的意思是，这种情况几乎一直持续到今天，即使在苏联解体之后。现在，既然你在乌克兰工作了大约八年，对于一个长期以来一直是被其最亲近邻国之一的目标的国家，你对这个国家的集体心态有什么看法？哇。这是一个了不起的问题。而且我，天哪，我喜欢历史。几个世纪以来，俄罗斯人一直（你知道）在他们背后虎视眈眈。
Absolutely. As have many other countries in that area. Yeah. I'm not sure I'm the best to speak to this, but I can speak to the qualitative work and what so many of our colleagues have said, you know, in country. there is definitely a lot of trust issues. And there's a lot of clarification of sides within the country. So just as an example, there is often a question of,
绝对是这样。该地区的许多其他国家也是如此。是的。我不确定我是谈论这个的最佳人选，但我可以谈谈定性工作以及我们在国内的许多同事所说的话。那里绝对有很多信任问题。而且国内有很多关于立场的澄清。所以作为一个例子，经常有一个问题，
do we translate the tool into Russian or Ukrainian? Right? Because a lot of people come from the area of Russia, have family in Russia, the older generations, may speak Russian better than they speak Ukrainian or more comfortable with them. So it's a real challenge. It's something that you're constantly working with and managing. I think feelings run really deep about that context. We heard a lot of just fatigue in the eight years that we worked there, that this war was just ongoing. Like I said, we worked with both veterans and internally displaced
我们是把工具翻译成俄语还是乌克兰语？对吧？因为很多人来自俄罗斯地区，在俄罗斯有家人，老一辈可能比说乌克兰语更会说俄语，或者对他们更舒服。所以这是一个真正的挑战。这是你不断工作和管理的事情。我认为人们对那种背景的感受非常深刻。在我们工作的八年里，我们听到了很多疲劳感，这场战争只是在持续。就像我说的，我们与退伍军人和国内流离失所者合作，
persons and a lot of the world didn't realize this was going on for a long time. There's already a lot of displaced people that had their homes and just their place of life taken away from them. And so I think there's a lot of anger and frustration. It's such a good question. I can only imagine how challenging it is for so many of them. And I ensure. are for sure worse right now. So, Dr. Murray, you were quoted in a recent Washington Post story about how people around the world, including here in the U.S., are providing remote mental health services to Ukrainians. How has the availability of remote or virtual services change the kind of work that mental health providers can do during a war or another natural disaster?
世界上很多人很长一段时间都没有意识到这一点。已经有很多人流离失所，失去了家园和生活的地方。所以我认为有很多愤怒和沮丧。这是一个很好的问题。我只能想象这对他们中的许多人来说是多么具有挑战性。而且我确定，现在肯定更糟了。所以，默里博士，你在最近一篇关于世界各地（包括美国这里）的人们如何为乌克兰人提供远程心理健康服务的《华盛顿邮报》报道中被引用。远程或虚拟服务的可用性如何改变了心理健康服务提供者在战争或其他自然灾害期间可以做的工作类型？
Wow. The advances in technology and our ability to deliver mental health care via technology has really been a game changer. We actually started studying this quite a few years before COVID hit. But when COVID hit the world, it propelled that at a speed and a rate of development that was awesome. And so we were really able to learn a lot about, who's able to deliver technology? What are the pros and cons? How do we handle safety situations? So again, for mental health providers out there, it's nerve-wracking to be on the phone or maybe even not video with someone and then they say they want to kill themselves. Like, how does that work with technology?
哇。技术进步以及我们通过技术提供心理健康护理的能力确实是一个游戏规则改变者。实际上，在新冠疫情爆发前几年，我们就开始研究这一点了。但当新冠疫情席卷全球时，它以一种令人敬畏的速度和发展率推动了这一点。所以我们确实能够学到很多关于谁能够提供技术？利弊是什么？我们如何处理安全情况？所以再次，对于那里的心理健康服务提供者来说，在电话上甚至可能没有视频的情况下与某人交谈，然后他们说他们想自杀，这让人神经紧张。这在技术上是如何运作的？
Maybe a phone drops. We actually did a study with Syrian refugees on the border where we couldn't reach them delivering technology-based intervention. We instituted this in Ukraine, so we were very well aware of how to use different apps, what apps worked well in different areas. We created completely separate manuals for how do you coach a provider to check in in different ways, especially if you don't have video, right? There's a need to just say, where are you, how are you, like who's in front of you, what's around you, are you still with me, especially with kids. who we all know struggle with attention span sometime. So we have learned just so much about it.
也许电话断了。我们实际上在边境对叙利亚难民进行了一项研究，我们无法接触到他们，只能提供基于技术的干预。我们在乌克兰实施了这一点，所以我们非常清楚如何使用不同的应用程序，哪些应用程序在不同地区效果良好。我们为如何指导服务提供者以不同方式进行检查创建了完全独立的手册，特别是如果你没有视频，对吧？需要说你在哪里，你怎么样，谁在你面前，你周围有什么，你还在我身边吗，特别是对孩子。我们都知道他们有时会为注意力持续时间而挣扎。所以我们确实学到了很多。
And I do think in this context, what's unique about this war and disaster is that we're not seeing all the refugees gather in refugee camps like we often do globally. They're moving and they're very spread out already. And so that's a real difference in a humanitarian response because they're not all in one area. And so technology is going to be incredibly needed in responding to this because they're not all in one place.
而且我确实认为在这种背景下，这场战争和灾难的独特之处在于，我们没有看到所有难民像我们在全球范围内经常看到的那样聚集在难民营中。他们正在移动，而且已经非常分散。所以这在人道主义响应中是一个真正的区别，因为他们并不都在一个区域。因此，在应对这一问题时，技术将非常需要，因为他们并不都在同一个地方。
And they are all over. And we've got to be able to find services in their local language, ideally. And ideally someone who understands their culture and some of that history and context, which of course comes up in the delivery of mental health services. So it has really advanced a lot. The other thing I will say is that USAID has been wonderfully supportive in also funding us to develop and refine a way to train providers from afar. That is huge.
而且他们遍布各地。我们必须能够找到他们当地语言的服务，理想情况下。理想情况下，有人了解他们的文化以及一些历史和背景，这当然会在心理健康服务的提供中出现。所以它确实进步了很多。我要说的另一件事是，美国国际开发署（USAID）也非常支持资助我们开发和完善一种从远处培训服务提供者的方法。这太重要了。
It's one thing to deliver services, but to be able to train providers using technology from afar where you don't need to be there in person is a huge advance and something that we're starting to use a lot with, for example, Ukrainian speakers all over the world who just want to help and give some of their time to be able to respond. So that raises another question, and I think this will be our final question. So as members of a helping profession, psychologists are often looking for ways to use their skills to help during major disasters, but not every psychologist is equipped to do this. There may be, as you've mentioned, there are language barriers, sometimes there are cultural barriers.
提供服务是一回事，但能够利用技术从远处培训服务提供者，而不需要亲自到场，这是一个巨大的进步，也是我们开始大量使用的方法，例如，世界各地只想提供帮助并贡献一些时间来响应的乌克兰语使用者。所以这提出了另一个问题，我认为这将是我们最后一个问题。因此，作为助人职业的成员，心理学家经常寻找方法利用他们的技能在重大灾难期间提供帮助，但并非每位心理学家都有能力这样做。正如你所提到的，可能存在语言障碍，有时存在文化障碍。
So what do you say to psychologists and other mental health providers who really want to do something, especially when the disaster is in another country. Yeah. First of all, thank you. I love how care providers are just right there ready to help, even though I'm sure they're very busy themselves. So I just love that spirit. I will say that in general, it's not good to go to places.
所以你对那些真正想做点什么，特别是当灾难发生在另一个国家时，心理学家和其他心理健康服务提供者有什么建议？是的。首先，谢谢你们。我喜欢护理提供者随时准备提供帮助，尽管我相信他们自己也非常忙碌。所以我只是喜欢那种精神。我要说的是，总的来说，去那些地方并不好。
That's one of the things that we talk a lot in global mental health. They actually have names for this, negative group, you know, negative ways of describing groups and sort of drop in and then fly out. Not very helpful. Honestly, in a context like this, one of the best things to do is to just find someone who's maybe doing this work that needs to be supported financially. I know there's a lot of providers who are willing to do this, but of course they have no jobs.
这是我们在全球心理健康中经常谈论的事情之一。他们实际上有名字来形容这个，负面群体，你知道，描述群体的负面方式，即空降然后飞走。不是很有帮助。老实说，在这种背景下，最好的事情之一就是找到一个可能正在做这项工作、需要经济支持的人。我知道有很多服务提供者愿意这样做，但当然他们没有工作。
Their organizations folded in. They're living in a different area. And so that's one way. to help. People have been very responsive also all over the world. We put out a call to say, would you be available? We could train you in the CETA system of care to respond. And I think that's a good way to help. In this context, better if you speak Ukrainian. But the other thing that we've actually put a call out for that I think I see a lot of need in humanitarian is being the voice on the other end that helps supervisors in these countries. So oftentimes supervisors often,
他们的组织倒闭了。他们住在不同的地区。所以这是帮助的一种方式。世界各地的人们反应也非常积极。我们发出呼吁说，你们愿意吗？我们可以培训你们使用CETA护理系统来响应。我认为这是一个很好的帮助方式。在这种背景下，如果你会说乌克兰语更好。但我认为我们在人道主义救援中看到的另一个需求是成为另一端帮助这些国家督导的声音。所以通常督导经常，
or higher level, higher educated folks might speak English. So that's an opportunity for English speakers, for example, to be the one that that supervisor can come to because that's often a lonely position. You're holding all that trauma and all that stuff of all your providers and all your providers have multiple clients. So that's a good place for people who are distant to come in with, you know, that level of need and support for them. Just one more comment, Kim, I so appreciate that you mentioned the cultural aspect because although we want to help, there are such deep cultural and historical aspects that you
或者更高层级、受过更高教育的人可能会说英语。因此，对于讲英语的人来说，这是一个机会，例如，成为主管可以求助的对象，因为那通常是一个孤独的位置。你承受着所有提供者带来的创伤和压力，而你所有的提供者都有多个客户。所以，对于那些身处远方的人来说，这是一个很好的切入点，可以提供那种程度的需求和支持。金，我还要补充一点，我非常感谢你提到了文化层面，因为尽管我们想提供帮助，但正如你在采访早些时候提到的那样，存在着深刻的文化和历史因素，如果你不了解这些，就很难提供支持并做出适当的反应。
brought up earlier in the interview also, that if you don't understand, it can be hard to support and to adequately respond. So I would just say, you know, look for opportunities where you feel like you might be needed. I know there's a lot of people asking for donations just to be able to continue their work, since this happens to be a country that does have a lot of professionals already. Well, Dr. Murray, I want to thank you for joining me. And I also want to thank you for the very important work that you are doing in Ukraine and elsewhere. wonderful to be here. Thanks so much, Kim. For more information on how mental health providers are
如果你不了解这些，就很难提供支持并做出适当的反应。所以我只想说，去寻找那些你觉得可能需要你的机会。我知道有很多人在寻求捐款，以便能够继续他们的工作，因为这个国家本身已经有很多专业人士了。好的，默里博士，我想感谢你接受我的采访。我也想感谢你在乌克兰和其他地方所做的非常重要的工作。很高兴来到这里。非常感谢，金。有关心理健康提供者如何提供帮助的更多信息，
helping in Ukraine, go to APA's website at www.apa.org. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology there and also at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're listening on Apple, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问美国心理学会（APA）网站 www.apa.org。你可以在那里找到《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）往期节目，也可以在 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及你获取播客的任何平台收听。如果你是在 Apple 上收听，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。